Hello and welcome to Python Bytes where we deliver Python news and
headlines directly to your earbuds.
This is episode 402 recorded September 23rd, 2024.
I'm Michael Kennedy.
And I'm Brian Okken.
This episode is brought to you by Scout APM.
We'll tell you more about them later.
If you want to keep up with us or the show, follow us on Mastodon.
Links are in the show notes or over on X.
If you really, really want to, you can find the links there
in the footer of the website.
We typically live stream on Mondays.
Now we used to do Tuesdays.
Remember we moved to Mondays.
So Mondays 10 a.m.
Pacific time on YouTube.
If you want to check that out, we'd love to have you.
Always great to have people in the audience, but certainly not the environment.
And finally, if you want to get artisanal handcrafted summary put together by your
very own Brian Okken about the show right after it ships, sign up for the newsletter.
Just go to PythonBites.fm/ right there and just click newsletter right at the front.
It's probably the easiest way actually.
But in your email, we won't, we won't do bad things with it.
We'll just send you updates.
So, and things about like horses and other stuff.
Horses, courses.
Okay.
Horses, courses for horses.
No, this is a totally different kind of show.
We go down that path.
Let's what path do you want to take?
Um, let, actually let's make some decisions.
Uh, how about that?
Yes.
Okay.
I actually, this was suggested to me actually at a work setting.
Um, a friend of mine, Christian Gazelle said, Hey, architectural decision
records are pretty cool.
Uh, do you use them?
And I had not heard of these things.
So I was excited to explore the rabbit hole.
So, this was, there's a article that we're going to link to.
This is the original from 2011 called documenting architecture
decisions from Michael Nygaard.
And, and it's, it, it's kind of this idea that you just have this lightweight
document to, to discuss things like, what you're deciding about, what the
context is, what, you know, what, what the current situation is, and then the
decision, what you're going to do.
And so the context is why, why you're doing it.
The decision is what you're going to do.
And then, you know, status, like if you're, whether you're
proposing it or whatever, I'm playing with status right now.
So, and then the consequences, what you hope to will be
the benefits of this decision.
This seems like, like, like so silly and simple that it can't be helpful, but it
is, it is awesome.
Um, and I've started using it just for a few days, so we'll see.
But, so there's another article I'd like to link to, and it's from, from
Red Hat called why you should be using ADRs or architectural decision records
to document your project.
And it's a, that's, that's a really nice, lightweight introduction.
Um, and, shows you basically you just had a handful of things and there's a
bunch of templates people are using.
I'm using Markdown.
Um, and I'm going to show you the, essentially the template I'm using.
It's just a Markdown file and I've got like a template, just a 0 0 0 ADR template
dot MD that just copy paste, modify.
And it's just a few lines.
And I've likely, sometimes I just put none in.
If I'm not considering any options, I'll just put none, but I might fill it in
later, but including pros and cons for options.
Um, this isn't, this is really only taking me a few minutes to get the stuff that
I'm thinking about or the project and the things I want to change out of my head.
And somewhere.
Um, and since it's in Markdown and I'm storing it with the, with the code in the
repository, it works great because, because the, because it's a GitHub or
GitLab just renders it it's Markdown.
So it just gets rendered and it looks beautiful.
Um, but it's super fast to just write this down.
Um, and I'm, I'm already like, in, so the step, okay.
I want to talk about the status a little bit.
The proposed status, the status that was recommended in the original is like
proposed, accepted, rejected, deprecated, superseded, and it's kind of formally.
So I've been using things like trying it out.
Um, haven't decided yet because I'm like documenting the process as I'm going.
And I'm guessing like, by the time I say accepted, I'm going to stop
editing these documents, but.
I've got a couple architecture things that I'm just trying out playing with,
you know, do be an agile about it.
And, and it's helping me to actually go even just back a day to say,
what was I thinking yesterday?
And, and having that written down someplace.
And then I'm also working with a remote team, so it's good to have the remote
team to be able to like, they can see what I'm thinking by reading these docs
and other people can do too.
So anyway, highly recommend architecture decision records.
Yeah, that's great.
You know, one thing that's might be cool to pair this with is the old style
GitHub projects, not the crummy new ones, but the good new, good old ones.
Okay.
Where you have counter on boards and they go through different stages, right?
So the status could be the columns of your projects and you could have just a
project for decisions and you could just see where they've gone and you know,
maybe, somehow reference.
Yeah.
And a great issue is something to link it all together through GitHub, but that'd be cool.
Definitely.
And I've seen, there's a bunch of people that have done a bunch of extra stuff on
top of this to make it more processy.
But to me, now it feels official and I don't want it to feel official.
I want it to just be like dumping stuff out of my head.
There's also a different, a different thing of like, how much things do you put in there?
Is it everything?
Is it, just big, important architectural changes and that you just sort of have, I'm
just playing with it to see what it is.
I'm not putting bug fixes in here, but I'm putting things like, I'm really changing
a component, taking it here and putting it over here.
Why am I doing that?
Right.
We're switching from FastAPI to flask and here's why.
Something like that, right?
So yeah.
Theoretically.
Awesome.
Well, let's go to the sea and visit some narwhals.
So I just had this, this project, had Marco Corelli on talk Python.
This is a project he's doing a lot of work with and narwhals, it solves a problem.
You can see their logo.
If you go to their website, it's a pandas and a polar bear in a narwhal
kind of hanging out behind them.
And the idea is if you have, if you are writing a library that takes a data frame
source, right?
So if you have users for doing pandas and they want to, you want to write, write a
library and say, Hey, send me your pandas data frame and I'll graph it or I'll analyze
it or I'll do AI around it or whatever it is you're doing with it.
You will probably get a message issue or something that says, Hey, we'd like you to
use polars.
How do I work with that?
I want to convert everything to pandas.
I want to use polar's like, now how do I take these two?
And then you're like, well, we actually use moden or we use, QPI for, GPU
programming.
Can we pass our data frames?
You're like, great.
Cause nobody wants to convert out of their native framework into this thing and into
some other one.
Cause it's probably going to make it slow.
Like if you convert out of a GPU into pandas, well, what's the point, you know?
So that's what the goal of this narwhals thing is.
It lets you primarily, it's primarily for people who are creating graphing libraries,
analysis libraries, others that can take all these different frameworks.
Okay.
Right.
And then what you do as the library writer is use a subset of the polar's API, a real
simple one program that comes from narwhals, but it's the same API.
Right.
And so you basically do that and then narwhals itself knows how to figure out
which data frame library you're working with, how to work with it.
If it's polar's and it does, it's lazy operations, it won't turn it into eager
operations that will continue to be lazy until it gets evaluated, which is really
good for performance and memory.
But if it's an eager API from pandas, also that very low overhead.
If you go check it out, full static typing, lots of promises of stability.
Because the point is to be a foundational library for other libraries, not cutting
edge, new features.
So anyway, if people are out there and they want to work with multiple frameworks for
whatever reason, especially if you're creating libraries that you want to let
people from different slices of the data science world use, then this is pretty
awesome.
So do you know, is it, it's not converting things as it brings it in, it's leaving it
in the native data.
Yes, exactly.
Yeah, exactly.
That's part of the bonus here is that it does that.
And then basically you write to the subset of the polar's API, but then narwhals
it's okay.
Well, is it really a pandas thing or whatever?
Yeah.
What's the underlying thing?
I don't have a direct use for it because I don't data science as much, but I think
it's cool and wanted to share it.
It will be on talk Python in much greater detail than I just explained in a couple of
weeks.
You can find it on the Python live stream YouTube section already, but the full
edited version will be out later.
All right.
That's pretty cool.
Yes, indeed.
And sure is.
How about we talk about our sponsor real quick, Brian, before we move on.
That sounds great.
Let me tell you real quick about Scout APM.
They're big supporters of Python bites.
So we appreciate that very much.
So if you are tired of spending hours trying to find the root cause of issues
impacting your performance, then you owe it to yourself to check out Scout APM.
They're a leading Python application performance monitoring tool, APM.
That helps you identify and solve performance abnormalities faster and easier.
Scout APM ties bottlenecks such as memory leaks, slow database queries, background
jobs, and the dreaded N plus one queries that you can end up if you do lazy loading
in your ORM, then you say, Oh no, why is it so slow?
Why are you doing 200 database queries for what should be one?
So you can find out things like that.
And it links it back directly to the source code.
So you can spend less time in the debugger and healing logs and just finding the
problems and moving on.
And you'll love it because it's built for developers by developers.
It makes it easy to get set up.
Seriously.
You can do it in less than four minutes.
So that's awesome.
And the best part is the pricing is straightforward.
You only pay for the data that used with no hidden overage fees or per seat pricing.
And I just learned this, Brian.
They also have, they provide the pro version for free to all open source projects.
So if you're an open source maintainer and you want to have Scout APM for that
project, just shoot them a message or something on their pricing page about that.
So you can start your free trial and get instant insights today.
Visit by them by set of him slash scout.
The link is in your podcast player show notes as well.
And please use that link.
Don't just search for them because otherwise they don't think you came from us.
And then they'd stop supporting the show.
So please use our link by them by set of him slash scout, check them out.
It really supports the show.
Well, next is, it's a little bit of bizarre news from the Northwest.
Um, the you're probably, so I'm, I'm a little bit older than you, I think.
Um, so I don't directly remember it, but I kind of remember the, the,
the meltdown at three mile Island.
And then I'm 27.
How old are you?
I'm just, so I was born in 1970, so I was nine years old.
So it wasn't really something I was completely aware of, but we, you know,
we heard about it later cause it was kind of a big deal.
So what this was, was a, nuclear nuclear facility in near, near Seattle.
Ish.
I don't know.
I'm not that good at geography.
Um, three mile Island in Washington.
And there were two reactors and one of them did a partial meltdown
and it was a big, big thing, but it was, it's the worst nuclear accident
we've had in the United States.
Um, and okay.
So why am I talking about this?
Well, I didn't, I guess, I guess I didn't realize it was still operating up until
2019, not those reactors.
There were other reactors nearby safer.
I mean, in nuclear energy has come a long way and there's, and actually this three
mile thing was the reason why we have a lot of the nuclear, regulations we
have now, it did sort of put nuclear energy on the back burner more than it
probably should have been.
And I'm not going to get into the politics of whether or not we should
have nuclear energy too much with that.
I didn't want to get into that too much, but what I am want to talk about is that
it's going to start up again or it's proposed to, so it was closed in 2019.
It might open again in 2028 and it's only going to be for Microsoft.
This is the bizarre bit.
So Microsoft, Microsoft wants to start this up again and have an exclusive 20
year deal for what 835 megawatts of energy.
Um, just going to AI.
Uh, this seems bizarre to me.
So the, so AI needs a lot of power and, and yeah, so that they're just
going to, they hope this isn't the still in proposal phase, regulators,
regulators have to approve it.
But, we're going to start up another nuclear power plant just
for, just for Microsoft AI.
This, I just don't get it.
Uh, so there's, there's that.
Um, and then it was, this was, we linked to the verge article.
I, I found it on the verge, but then I searched for it again.
Some more, and there's just a CNN article as well.
And also what it looks like.
There's only one picture of this thing that's being used everywhere.
Uh, anyway.
Oh, I guess that's a different picture, but, so kind of start up again.
Uh, it seems odd.
Uh, and then, in a related news, I guess that's all I just wanted to say
is, I think this is weird that we're going to start a nuclear power plant just for AI.
Maybe that's a problem.
Uh, anyway, the article I found was, just, it's kind of a mock news article,
but this is just a mixed weenies, internet tendency.
The article is the department of energy wants you to know that your conservation
efforts are making a difference.
So I thought we were trying to like save the planet by saving energy and stuff.
And, this has got some interesting bits.
Um, it says, by turning off your lights all day, every day, you can serve
about 1% of the energy needed for AI to generate a picture of a duck wearing
sunglasses is an EQ, aside from the fact that he has feet that are a human of a
human man, of course.
Um, so AI is consuming tons of energy and we're in the rest of our lives.
We're trying to conserve energy.
That's just a, I don't know.
I, maybe I shouldn't brought it up as a topic.
It's just seems bizarre to me.
So I'll leave it there.
Well, so I love these.
Let's put your, your feeling bad about wasting energy or your effort to save
some energy and perspective.
And it's just like, yeah, I mean, I still go around and turn off the lights after
my kid who just like leaves them on.
Well, yeah.
And also we're, I've like stopped buying 25 cent light bulbs and now we buy $8 LED
light bulbs that last about the same as the other bulbs used to.
And they are more, I mean, we're spending way more on light bulbs and for what?
So that AI can have more energy, I guess.
Yeah.
So on one side, I totally see the point there on the other.
If we're going to dump tons of energy into AI, I would much rather see it coming from
carbon neutral sources than coal plants, you know, true fair, right?
Like, are you going to make the duck or are you going to not make the duck?
Like regardless of what light bulbs using people are making ducks and let's do that.
Better.
I think it's super bizarre that three mile Island is the choice because if there's
anything in at least American culture that says nuclear energy bad, it's three miles.
Like anywhere else, you know?
Yeah.
Well, they're going to change the name.
It's going to be called the crane clean energy center.
Oh, there's a good rebranding that, that said I'm super optimistic on
nuclear energy as a climate solution.
Not necessarily old school three mile Island stuff, but the molten salt
reactors, the things that fail safe and not fail explosive like Fukushima.
Right.
I know there's nuclear waste.
There are less, those new ones are less bad.
And you know, I feel like a lot of the pushback against it.
It's a little bit like, well, there's this rare endangered lizard in the desert.
So we can't have in this desert, any solar farms.
It's like, well, if it gets 20 degrees hotter, there's going to
be no lizards in the desert.
We need to take some more positive action.
And I feel like, you know, nuclear energy is that sort of in the extreme, right?
People have such strong reactions, but there's so much better tech now.
And I would love to see that.
Yeah.
My personal views are that I think it would be good to utilize what we have,
including nuclear energy as a stop gap to get us off carbon based fuel.
And then once we get that, we can get carbon neutral.
Then we can go to, then we can be, as we beef up solar and, and wind
and everything, then we can maybe draw away from nuclear.
That's a great way to put it.
Like let's get rid of the carbon pollution and then we can debate
of the things that are working, which ones are working best.
Very well.
I also wanted to point out the excellent pun that you made intentional or not,
that with nuclear energy, people have strong reactions.
That's very good.
All right.
People might have a strong reaction to this as well, but I got to
say it's way less, way less out there.
So here's the strong reaction.
I think when people use Docker, so this is a Docker topic.
When people use Docker, there's two philosophies.
One philosophy is I want the lightest weight, simplest, most basic thing that
I can possibly use to build my containers.
So they're insanely small, right?
I want almost nothing there.
I just want, if it is not needed for whatever I'm trying to do to execute,
it doesn't belong there.
Let's get it out of there.
Yeah.
That's one side.
Does this topic is not from that topic is from the other side of perspective
that I would say the Michael side lives on that I live on in that is Docker can be
more difficult to understand what's going wrong when something goes wrong.
How do you fix it?
How do you get other tools to see what's happening inside there?
Right.
And so I think there's a bunch of people that stay away from Docker because
they're like, Oh, I just want to have access to the logs and the, the tools
that I normally use and all that kind of stuff inside my server or my VM.
So I can understand what's happening better.
Right.
So one of the tools I really like is, Oh, my Z shell, right.
With all of his plugins is auto-complete is cool history.
And so I present to you ZSH in Docker.
It installs Z shell.
Oh, my Z shell and the plugins like auto-complete for source control and for,
um, you know, all the, all the various plugins that you get right from Z shell.
And it's one line.
So you put this run shell at the, the, the, out of this repo and it just installs
Z shell and installs, Oh, my Z shell.
It makes it the default shell.
Or you just run it when you get into it, whatever.
And then all the plugins, et cetera.
So really, really nice.
You even get to pick your theme as part of the one liner so that you can see
like what version of Python is active.
What is the state of a get repo?
If you copied a get repo in as part of setting up your Docker container
and all those kinds of things.
So super simple.
If you believe in the, I want some tools inside of my container.
So when things are not working, I can exec into it and ask what's going on.
And this is really awesome.
Uh, if you don't want that, if you're in the opposite side, this is not for you.
All right, cool.
Indeed.
So do you, how much time do you spend in Docker?
Uh, very little, but when things are not quite working or I'm trying to figure out
a command, you know, maybe you've got a database running in there and you're
like, I really need to see, I just want to see what's going on with this.
And you know that inside the container, there's some database management tools.
If you just Docker exec Z shell, and then you start typing, it's like you're, you're
just on SSH in effectively.
So, yeah, I'm going to have to check that out.
So I'm changing my doc.
Like I used to use Docker a lot for like actually cross compiling, C++ code.
And I'm using it more now for web stuff.
Um, and so, yeah, absolutely.
I think it's great.
And obviously I do a ton of stuff with Docker and for running the web apps and
things, but I don't go into the web apps unless I have questions.
You know, but when you do, it's nice to just go, oh, okay, well, here's the thing.
And you just make this one of your base layers of your Docker image
and it builds nice and fast.
Nice.
Okay.
Um, well, we're, ran through our topics.
Um, I don't have any extras today, so you're extra less.
I'm extra list.
What is the opposite of extra?
I don't know.
I got a few basic, maybe I guess bear the bare minimums.
Okay.
So first one is I remember I spoke about this thing, this uptime Kuma while ago.
Uptime Kuma is great.
So it's self-hosted, free uptime monitoring.
Okay.
Well, I put in a bunch of things, like for example, if you go to Python bytes and you
go to the bottom and hit server status, it'll show you the server status of Python
bytes, how old the SSL search from let's encrypt are and all those kinds of things.
Right.
Very cool.
Well, I turned that on all of my web things.
Including my personal blog, which this might resonate with you, Brian is my
personal blog built with Hugo, which is a static site, so it cannot crash.
It is HTML, CSS image.
Like you can't crash.
Right.
And I thought, Oh, I'm going to host this on Netlify because
Netlify is pretty awesome.
Right.
Yeah.
Well, I started getting every single day or every other day, your site has a five
Oh two error and it's been down for 10 minutes.
Now it's back.
It's been down.
What?
How could it possibly?
It's a static site.
So something about the Netlify infrastructure was going bonkers.
And I will tell you if you already have an Intunix server laying around somewhere,
it's about eight or nine lines of code of Intunix configuration to just host it yourself.
So I switched this over to running on server that runs all the other things that I got,
but because Netlify was crashing.
So I think the takeaway is not that mkennedy.code is my personal blog, website,
consider is hosted anywhere different.
Like, why do you care?
But if you're hosted on Netlify, maybe point some uptime status at your thing,
even though it's a static site, shouldn't fail.
Look at it anyway.
Mine was for a week or two.
I would say at least two weeks, it has been all sorts of broken temporarily.
So is it better now?
Yeah, it's perfect.
Cause why would it have any problems now?
It's on our server.
Yeah, it's better now.
Okay.
So that's number one.
That's just a, check that out.
Number two, over at Talk Python, if you go to the courses and you go to the apps, we've
really nice new version that came out, I think last year of our mobile apps for all
the courses, including Brian's pytest course.
You can take it that way.
The one that comes from Talk Python that is.
Well, the guy who wrote this, Lauren Auge, I had him on Talk Python when we talked
about Python and mobile apps along with some other folks.
Anyway, he used to be a live sound engineer until COVID hit.
And then he moved over into software development and he wrote up a really
detailed story of his life journey.
And I just wanted to share that if people are interested in that, maybe you're making
that transition as well, then, you know, check that out.
It's pretty cool.
That's pretty cool.
Yeah.
This other short one comes to us from it.
Itmar Turner.
I Turner trowing says it's time to stop using Python three, eight.
I can't believe that, but it is.
He puts it, he puts it onto our radar that, you know, 14% of the packages
downloaded from PyPI are for Python three, eight installations.
And by the way, next month it's going end of life out of supported, no
virus, no security fixes, nothing.
So you might not want that to be your foundation if you get to choose.
And we got like seven days left to September.
Yeah.
I would say it's yeah, five weeks.
What could go wrong?
Anyway, just put it on your radar.
Maybe Python three 12.
It's been out for a long time.
Version six of that one just came out.
So I think we're good.
You know, three, 12, six.
Oh, I also want to add to that, that since like, it's been years since I've ever
had any, any significant issue upgrading.
Um, at most I'll see deprecations that I have to go through and, and
clean up or warnings or something.
But I, maybe other people have, but I haven't had any issues,
for really long time upgrading.
So, yeah, same.
I did have an issue with, I can't remember.
There was some, it was packages that didn't support three 12.
There was some deprecation in there that I had to wait three or four weeks before
I could start using three 12 when it first came out for some of my apps.
However, that's not the same as to say that Python itself is unreliable.
You would know right away if the imports fail or whatever, right?
Like you'll, you'll find out straight away.
And so, yeah.
And I don't remember the reason why, but on a couple of the projects that I've
converted from three eight to three 12, work projects, I jumped to from three
eight to three 10 with no issues or minor issues and then to three 12 fairly easy.
And for some reason it just helped me to go from three 10 and then three 12.
Uh, but anyway, your mileage may vary.
It's these, it's these kinds of things that if you don't do it, you eventually
end up saying we have a two six app and a half million lines of code and
it's still running on Python two six.
So don't talk to me about your fancy new libraries and your typing and your async.
We're just trying to survive, you know, like, but if you keep, if you get into
the practice of just like, okay, well, let's just keep this stuff moving.
All those steps are generally small unless you try to take them 10 years at a time.
They're stressing me out, man.
PTSD from two six.
All right.
Last thing.
So pass keys.
Let me ask you really quick, Brian, are you a pass key user?
Yes.
Well, pass key is in believer.
Well, yeah, I use pass keys.
Yeah.
I do too.
I've been resisting using pass keys.
So pass keys are cryptographic kind of like, almost like SSH keys, but for the
normal normal folks for just web authentication, right?
So cryptographic thing, blob that gets put into your, whatever thing is signing
in and if it shares that back, it's supposed to be dedicated to that instance.
It knows it's you.
Often you can skip to a phase, all those kinds of things.
Right.
But one of the things that really turned me off on pass keys is they felt to me,
like a couple of the tech giants are like, Hey, this is a sweet opportunity for lock-in.
So let's see how much lock-in we can get, you know, Android and Apple, especially
right, like, Hey, just save your pass key to your iPhone.
What could go wrong?
I was like, well, I could lose my, yeah.
If I could lose my iPhone or even if it's synced to iCloud, like what?
I have a smart TV that says, you know, log in with your password.
It's a super pain to type in, but you can do it.
Or maybe I'll go over to my windows PC and I have to type in some password to log in.
A lot of times it'll say like, Oh, your Microsoft account is expired.
It's login, login again at the boot screen.
So I don't get access to anything.
I was like, Oh my gosh, this is a pain.
But those situations get way worse.
If you have pass keys that are dedicated to, you know, one provider, right.
That's, that's just a mega lock-in.
So I realized that if you're a one password user or I think also bit warden, I'm a user of both of
them and I really like them.
If you store your pass keys there, all of a sudden they live everywhere.
It's beautiful.
And if your computer gets destroyed, just log into one password or it wouldn't or whatever
again, and you have them all again.
So if you at least for one password, if you go into the watchtower, there's a section that
says, show me all the sites that could have past keys that I don't have stored past keys for
here, and it'll help you go through and basically add the no one password, which is a form of
lock-in, but a much lower grade form of lock-in in my, my feeling.
So anyway, I am now a believer of past keys.
I believe I went through and did that this weekend.
I added like 35 accounts or so that have past keys and now life's a little easier.
Like GitHub, for example.
Yeah.
Nice.
So, all right.
You have the joke for us this week.
Do you not?
I do.
And I actually, I thought it was going to be a topic.
I just had it in my, in my backlog of how to monetize a blog.
And then I started reading it and realized this is just a hilarious joke.
And I love it.
So I wanted to bring it up here.
And so, and you should either, if you're listening and not, not on YouTube, you should
watch the, watch the video version or just go check it out yourself.
I'll link in the show notes.
Okay.
So how to monetize a blog.
I talked to, and I actually thought it was going to be advice, but it's just funny.
Maintaining a blog can be a lot of work.
I started reading it.
You don't really need to read it.
There's some fun font that shows up right away.
Like, like there's, it can become a fairly lucrative venture and the become is in this
wacky font.
I love the M that's cool.
And then so you're going down and you see these various things like, like TimberQuest
advertisement, your lumberyard awaits you, my Lord.
Play now.
And almost all the, the, the clickable things, if you click on them, they just like pop up
little coins.
You don't actually go anywhere.
And then talks about slapping this bad boy here can start raking in some cash through
true primary means CPM or CPA.
And and then you just sort of, if it's sort of seems reasonable, but it says, look, look,
how am I doing so far?
I've, I've made 0.123 cents so far on this.
And then it just adds it up.
There's different various various little links around that if you click on them, it
increases the how much money this person's made, even though it's not real.
But if you, I just started reading the ads, like there's an ad for minimal effort
graphic design, no proofing and time to say the ads are hilarious.
Here's one free cruise sign up today with eligible purchase meeting or exceeding value
of cruise, after which no purchase is necessary.
Of course, click on that guy for some extra cents.
Let's see.
I'll read one.
The more clicks and grizzly bear sales you can squeeze out of your beloved readers, the
more of their money you can siphon to spend on cheeseburger deliveries.
And of course, cheeseburger deliveries is clickable.
It's got to be an affiliate link, right?
Yeah.
All these things.
Uh, let's see.
Uh, here's a little, a little weird thing.
Uh, add on the side that looks like a Amazon or eBay thing.
Friendship assembly, 1595 collapsible by valve, and a that which
molts beneath enclosures toy.
This is bizarre.
I love these.
I'm going to scroll down more literal snake oil, vials of freshly
squeezing, squeezing oil from actual snakes.
Um, befriend a sandwich.
No doctors allowed.
The first mystery grab bag of unmarked vitamins is free.
Um, oh, and then it pops up.
We get a pop up, push notifications.
Would you like to enable push notifications so you can receive
intrusive alert messages like these outside of the browser?
Yes.
Or ask me later.
Uh, I'm sure I said yes.
And see if you got a coin for that.
Yeah, maybe let's do it again.
Another one.
Yes.
Oh yeah.
Oh, you did.
You make, get some money for that.
Yeah.
And a weird pop-up cheese cube burger now open.
Uh, let's see.
We soon become, oh, it's too bad.
You can't see this.
This one is a ice cream holding tips.
Um, there's, we have radishes that will change your life.
Add, let's see.
Uh, huh.
Oh, these, these are my, these are just my mind rending.
God radishes, old school.
Um, excuse me, a virus was detected on a computer.
Send bit points like a Solaris window.
Um, oh, anyway.
And then you, you just sort of scroll down.
It just comes, it becomes even more bizarre.
You've got sideways text.
Uh, and then, the, the spiral, this is awesome.
I don't even know.
So I was like, how did they do some of this stuff?
It's pretty cool.
It's some pretty cool stuff.
Uh, monetize.
That's how you do it.
Yeah.
If you go all the way down also in the, if you actually start reading it, it says
stuff like there's not actually, you just sort of have to spew out lots of words.
I didn't even edit this.
Um, and then way at the bottom, there's a credits, how this was made.
And then, this person goes through and walks through, basically all
the different, procedures for how, like how to do the spiral, how to do the
cool font, and all these sort of tricks, with HTML and CSS and whatnot.
So anyway, just a hilarious little, blog on stupid ads.
Um, that's awesome.
Andre out there says this is art.
It's definitely art.
Yeah.
Not art, but real time follow up.
Bitwarden also supports pass keys, which Bitwarden being open source and the
paid version is insanely affordable.
It's like a dollar, a couple of dollars a year or something.
I can't remember exactly what it is, but maybe that's the proper
recommendation there for, for pass keys.
But anyway, pretty cool.
Yeah.
Cool.
Well, let's call it a show, huh?
Yeah.
It sounds good.
All right.
Well, thanks for being here.
Thank you everyone for listening.
See y'all later.